Eric function y equals e to the X so
first of all what what exactly is e
right well e is one of those numbers
like pi right where you can't really you
know write it as a fraction it's a
irrational PI you know is 3.14159 it
keeps going right but it doesn't repeat
it doesn't stop he is also similar to
that you know it's approximately 2.7 1
and again it doesn't repeat and it
doesn't stop but what we can do here to
get a quick graph is we can make a table
okay I'll just make a little XY table
and we're going to pick a couple of
values here negative 1 0 1 & 2 okay so
first let's start with 0 anything to the
0 power always equals 1 so that's 0 1
I'm just going to plot that right in our
graph right there 1 e to the 1st is just
going to be e which we know is about two
point seven one or two point seven so
I'm going to plot that point so one and
two point seven which is just a little
bit shy of three and if we put two in we
get e squared okay which is two point
seven times two point seven
approximately so let's just see what
that comes out to a square I'll do on
the calculator it's seven about seven
point four okay so we're here at two one
two three four five six seven point four
right about there and then negative one
what the negative one tells you to do is
it tells you that take the reciprocal so
this is actually 1 over e to the
positive one so that's going to be 1
over e which is about one over two point
seven which is about 1/3 ok so we're at
negative one about 1/3 right there so
what you can notice here is that this
graph starts off like this and then it
starts to grow faster faster faster like
that it's an exponential growth function
and you can see it's as X gets larger Y
gets larger at a faster and faster rate
now over here it's approaching the
x-axis but it never touches and never
crosses so this is what we call an
asymptote ok that's spelled asy MPT OTE
asymptotes and it just means that it's
approaching that line you know but it
doesn't it doesn't cross it here it just
approaches it so in this case the domain
would be all real numbers it can go to
the left to the right without bound
without stopping and the range would be
all the Y values greater than but not
equal to zero so just Y is greater than
now let's look at this one over here y
equals e to the negative X now at first
glance you might think that this is an
exponential growth function okay because
you know you've got that that base e
which is greater than 12.7 but remember
what the negative exponent does this is
really saying 1 over e to the X now in
the base so these functions are by the
way they're in the form y equals a B to
the X if the base is greater than 1 it's
going to grow like this one to the right
but if the base is in between 0 and 1
then it's going to be what we call a
decay function it's going to decrease ok
so as X is increasing Y is going to be
decreasing but again what I would do is
just make a table like we did over here
just pick some you know easy values
maybe like negative 1 0 & 1 and let's go
ahead and put those in so 1 over e to
the negative 1 the negative 1 just takes
the reciprocal so that's just gonna be e
to the first which is about 2.7 so if
I'm over here at negative 1 I'm up here
at 2.7 of course anything to the zero
power is going to be 1 so that's going
to be right here 0 1 and then anything
to the first power is going to be itself
so 1 over e to the first is just 1 over
e and remember E is about 2.7 so it's
about 1/3 so over here we're at 1 1/3 so
what you can see here is it's decreasing
decreasing decreasing its approaching
x-axis it doesn't touch it doesn't cross
it
that's our horizontal asymptote the line
y equals 0 okay now let's get into a
little bit more challenging one this one
here so you probably studied in some of
your other chapters and other sections
in your math class transformations and
so what you can see here is happening
this number this group with the ax it's
gonna pick up the graph and shift it in
the X direction but opposite from the
sine so what I mean by that is minus 1
is actually going to shift it to the
right one if it was plus 1 it would
actually shift it to the left one okay
so this is shifting it right 1 and then
the plus 3 is going to shift it up 3 so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to go
right 1 up 3 I'm gonna draw a little
open circle on we're gonna think about
that as our new starting point or our
new origin and I'm gonna draw in a
dashed line or a dotted line we're going
to think of that as our new x-axis or
our new asymptote our horizontal
asymptote this is the line y equals 3
and then now what we're gonna do is
we're just going to focus in on the pair
function okay that's what's left over
after we've taken into account the
translation or the shift and again we
can just go ahead and make a table here
so we're just gonna pick some easy
values negative one zero in one small
value so it doesn't go off our graph
okay get too large or too small where
it's hard to plot and so we can say e to
the negative one is one over e times two
which is two over E now remember E is
about two point seven so if we just
quickly go to our calculator it's a two
divided by two point seven approximately
we're looking at about 0.7 for 0.75
approximately I'll just run it about
like that so this is going to be
negative one
now when you graph these points you
don't want to graph from this origin you
want to graph from the shifted origin
okay because we've already taken the
shift into account so this is going to
be left one okay and then up 0.75
approximately right there okay now if we
put zero in anything to the zero is one
times two is two so we're over here at
which this is our starting point so 0 up
to and then if we put in one anything
the first power is itself so that's
going to be e which is two point seven
times two which is about five point four
so from here when you go right one up
one two three four five point four okay
so you can see what we've got here same
graph okay essentially but the two is
stretching it and the one in the three
are picking up the graph and shifting it
right and up okay so that's the idea in
this case the domain would be all real
numbers because it goes to the left and
the right without bound and the range is
going to be the Y's are greater than
three see the asymptotes here it's at
three so greater than three so I hope
this helped you to understand how to
graph exponential functions with the
natural base e if you're enjoying these
math videos consider supporting me on
patreon I'll have a link for that and
subscribe to the channel check out more
math videos on Mario's math tutor and
YouTube channel and I look forward to
helping you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon